it's not a pyramid scheme it is a it's
not even a scheme per se it's
i have to go make a call
this
just
stinks don't touch it please don't touch
it
bye
bye
miss chair model lady
a jump that we were married and you
treated me nice
it's britney [ __ ]
poop is raining from the ceilings
poop like a like a blue shirt i don't
wear a lot of colors
just make that copy okay
ryan started the fire
it was always burning since the world
returning ryan started the fire
it was always fun everybody
and i feel god in this chili's tonight
i burned my foot very badly on my
foreman grill and i now need someone to
come and bring me into work ryan
is uh
dead goodbye
i don't know what that
was oh my god
it is your birthday period statement of
fact andy and dwight
are rocking the sales team i feel very
blessed
[Music]
stop it no
come on
wait don't open your mouth no michael
we're making love island's in the stream
that is what we are
no one in between so tell me what do you
want to be when you grow up
i want to be married and have a hundred
kids so i can have a hundred friends and
no one can say no to being my friend
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
bye ryan
you seem nice whenever you come into the
office i want you to think about this
we don't need to
yes we do what
thank you
you don't even know my real name
i'm the lizard king i am about to do
something very bold this job that i've
never done before
try
i wonder what people like about me
probably my jugs
this is a business scenario right
i
am a victim of a hate crime
stanley knows what i'm talking about
that's not what a hate crime is well i
hated it a lot okay i
hey i thought you weren't supposed to
eat anything for a couple of hours after
you've had a crown put in
having this new kind of quick drying
bonding
sounds like a good dentist oh yeah
what's his name
cran test
your dentist's name is krentist
what
is michael scott's
greatest fear
um loneliness
maybe women
don't drop the soap don't drop the soap
michael please
feeling
feeling
there's too many people on this earth we
need a new plague
[Music]
is he okay
[Music]
happy birthday to cave oh get out
skeleton man
andy's running over dwight with his car
oh
be continued
it said specifically that
[Music]
oh god
oh god
we're nipples
it's starting
open open into the hangar there you go
yep eat it
put it in your mouth and just eat it
i hate it
the man exudes sex
we're moving to colorado
all of us yep
a bunch of prudes you know oscar's
allowed to wear sandals but i'm not
alone we're open to it
is that how it goes
meredith your boob is out fine
no no
damn it meredith where are your panties
casual day jan is about to have a baby
with a sperm donor and michael is
preparing for the birth of a watermelon
with dwight
now this baby will be related to michael
through
delusion
the kgb will fit for no one this trip is
longer than i thought yeah it did look
shorter
hey
say hello to daddy
me okay you know what trade big boobs
with a z that's
the password we're in whenever i'm about
to do something i think would an idiot
do that and if they would i do not do
that thing
he knows where it is
remain calm i have trained for this
okay
exit the window here we go make a u-turn
if
[Music]
come on
you